i think homophobia can actually be kind  of dangerous you know a friend of mine  he's kind of a tough guy he went  skydiving recently he's like yeah i'm  not strapping some guy in my back that's  super gay yeah now he's dead  sometimes i wish i was gay you know i  got fired from my last job for sexual  harassment i told a woman she had nice  cleavage they fired me  which pissed me off because my gay  friends at work would get away with  murder they beg hey shelly how are you  honk honk  it's like what why is that okay like  well not attracted to women i was like  so what i'm not attracted to kids i  can't go to a playground hey timmy get  over here  [Applause]  i don't get stuff like that you know i  i'm trying to learn but you know like  you're a woman wouldn't you rather